[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il est temps il est vraiment
temps d'être un homme
voici la dir je ne vous parle pas de
caractéristiques physiques
physiologiques ou morphologiques qui
précise le genre de comparer le masculin
ou le féminin non je vous parle d'être
un homme
simone de beauvoir disait on ne naît pas
femme on le devient
mais comment savoir que je suis devenu
un homme
et puis ça veut dire quoi être un homme
messieurs si nous reprenons notre ligne
du temps de vie à quel moment avez vous
su senti que vous étiez devenus des
hommes au moment de votre majorité
quand vous avez vécu un exploit sportif
qui vous a amené au dépassement physique
quand vous vous êtes battus contre un
autre homme et que vous avez remporté la
victoire lors de votre première
expérience sexuelle
quand vous avez traversé votre première
cuite n'ont en tout cas pas pour moi et
vous mesdames
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait que je dise que
je fasse que je sois là maintenant pour
que vous vous disiez lui c'est un homme
c'est dingue mais c'est à l'âge de 45
ans que j'ai touché la sensation plein
d'être un homme en vivant des
expériences avec des hommes
oui c'est parce que vous imaginez tout a
commencé en 2015
j'étais en train de préparer une journée
de facilitation pour accompagner un
groupe avec deux de mes amis
ramuntxo evil il son coach et
facilitateur en intelligence collective
comme moi et j'étais en train de
dessiner des consignes sur un paperboard
quand je les observais de l'autre côté
de la salle il y avait quelque chose de
différent
leur façon de rire leur promiscuité leur
engagement leur manière d'être
ça m'a amené à traverser la salle et à
leur demander bon les gars là vous avez
fait quelque chose tous les deux
hammouche aussi retourné m'a fait un
grand sourire et m'a dit d'une manière
très amusé gerome on a fait un truc de
malade entre hommes
mais je ne pourrai rien à te dire bien
évidemment ça a piqué ma curiosité
alors je les ai cuisine et un peu et ne
m'ont rien dit du tout et pourtant je
sentais que derrière leur retenue et
leur joie amusé il avait vécu une
expérience très forte
le samedi suivant
je me suis inscrit j'ai participé à
cette aventure je ne vous raconterai pas
non plus ce qu'il s'y passe parce qu'il
y à certaines choses qui ne se raconte
pas il suffit
mais je vais vous partagez comment cette
expérience a impacté ma vie ne vous
est-il jamais arrivé d'écouter le jt de
20h et en entendant un homme de 32 ans a
abattu sa femme à mort à
garges-lès-gonesse les voisins sont
consternés ou encore des habitants ont
été pris en otage par un groupe armé ont
été massacrés à coups de machette dans
un village du burundi ou peut-être plus
récents une vague de boue a traversé la
commune de lisieux et amis 350 personnes
en situation d'urgence
polémique sur le plan d'occupation des
sols
moi je me disais un peu comme vous bon
c'est terrible mais qu'est ce que je
peux y faire
et ben moi durant ce week-end j'ai mis
les pieds dans la boue dans la boue des
de la violence des hommes vis-à-vis des
hommes des hommes vis-à-vis des femmes
des hommes vis-à-vis de la planète
nous étions trente six hommes français
belges hollandais à vivre cette
expérience et nous étions accompagnés
par 36 autres hommes
symboliquement pas possible de s'enfuir
non j'étais là je regardais j'entendais
je vivais ses 36 cette histoire d'hommes
la mienne y comprise et je ne pouvais
pas faire autrement que de faire face à
ce potentiel et ce pouvoir de violence
cette violence
à l'encontre des hommes à l'encontre des
femmes
cette violence ça peut aller de la
simple moqueries à la maltraitance ou
voire pire au plus abjecte au meurtre et
au viol il n'y a rien de plus absurde
que de comparer le viol d'une femme avec
le viol d'un homme ça n'a pas de sens
ce qui est important c'est que cette
violence s'arrête
et ça ça ne dépendait que de nous ça ne
dépendait que de moi
oui si je prends un prisme planétaire
mais nous sommes violent cette violence
c'est ce magot de cigarettes
c'est ce paquet de cigarettes et ce bout
de plastique que je balance à travers la
fenêtre de ma voiture
cc pollution massive ou voire pire
la destruction nucléaire bon ok la bombe
h c'est un peu too much mais jean louis
aubert
il disait bien que la bombe humaine tu
la tiens dans ta main cette violence
c'est l'accumulation de nos propos nos
paroles nos actes
ils viennent influencer et mettre en
péril l'équilibré des relations des
hommes entre les hommes des hommes entre
les femmes des hommes et de la planète
où elle ce pouvoir de violence il n'y a
qu'une chose pour le contrebalancer
c'est le pouvoir du choix je les saisies
se pousse de ce pouvoir en prenant
conscience oui en prenant conscience que
moi aussi je pouvais être un homme
violent prendre conscience
et prendre le temps de faire un pas en
arrière et de sentir de mesurer ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de moi pour
m'offrir un espace de changement oui
cette violence contre cette violence
il ya un élément important ce n'est pas
se battre contre ma violence parce que
me battre contre ma violence ça peut
amener aussi de la violence
ça peut amener de la dépression ça peut
amener de la de l'addiction non non
prendre sa responsabilité
voilà une chose importante c'est la
première chose importante
si je regarde ses 36 hommes nous ont
apporté une chose incroyable de la
bienveillance sans complaisance de
l'amour inconditionnel
je n'en avais jamais reçu autant vivre
et partager des moments dansés cercle
d'hommes m'amène une respiration pour
éviter un danger le danger de l'inaction
agir s'est activé le courage à
l'intérieur de soi activer un alignement
une intégrité l'intégrité c'est honorer
de mes actes l'engagement que j'ai pris
vis-à-vis des autres vis-à-vis de
moi-même vis-à-vis de la planète
comment tous les jours nous agissons
avec responsabilité et avec intégrité
jusqu'en 2015 2017
j'étais vraiment plu à certif je m'étais
beaucoup d'énergie dans mes projets
personnels ou professionnels
j'avais envie d'emmener et d'accompagner
aussi des hommes mais il y avait un
petit sujet que je fuyais la sexualité
oui ce sujet de la sexualité
si vous tapez sexe ou sexualité sur
internet vous trouver de tout le pire
comme le meilleur
et dans le meilleur j'ai découvert le
mot tentera hockey quand je vous dis
tentera qu'est ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit
je vous le donne en mille j'ai choisi de
vivre une expérience tantrique entre
hommes
c'était tout sauf ceux que je connais
j'avais peur et je me disais c'est
justement là qu'il faut aller
alors j'y suis allé oui l'expérience
tantrique il y avait 45 hommes 45 hommes
autour de moi d'orientation sexuelle
variés alors je me sentais dilué ça
c'était cool aborder le champ du tentera
cette voie de sagesse ancestrale
intellectuellement c'est déjà quelque
chose mais il y aller oui j'étais là
avec ses 45 hommes mais il faut dire que
moi ma voix ancestrales ça commençait
par playboy
emmanuel les discussions entre potes peu
ou pas des changes avec mon père le
fameux tu mettras des capotes de ma mère
et l'article 22 démerde toi comme tu
peux ouais je repense même à madame
paule et ma prof de sciences nat en
sixième qui nous avait enseigné de
manière magistrale la reproduction avec
la perforation de la membrane ovules
airs par le spermatozoïde en balbutiant
d'une manière effacé que pour arriver à
ce résultat il fallait que le sexe de
l'homme ses origines hi fi comme le
tuyau d'arrosage du jardin le gap non
pendant ces quatre jours de tentera bien
évidemment j'ai découvert de la
mécanique musculaire sexuelle d'aborder
le désire mais surtout j ai découvert
une approche énergétique spirituel
j'ai redécouvert le pouvoir de la
violence de la violence des hommes
vis-à-vis des femmes des hommes
vis-à-vis des hommes et parfois même des
femmes vis-à-vis des femmes vis-à-vis
des hommes
oui ce tentera ça a été quelque chose
d'important pour moi et je peux dire que
je me souviens quand j'ai annoncé à ma
femme que j'allais vivre une expérience
tantrique avec des hommes je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie
croyez moi
tous les matins je me lève en me disant
que j'apporterai forcément ma
contribution vis-à-vis de la violence
tous les matins je me remercie d'avoir
choisi de vivre ces expériences uniques
parce que je peux apporter cette
contribution unique au monde parce que
je me sens puissant et qu'il est
possible de le faire avec beaucoup
d'humour et avec beaucoup d'amour oui
j'aime les hommes
oui j'aime les femmes
et j'aime surtout ma planète quand j'ai
vécu le tantra je me suis sentie
vulnérables littéralement vulnérables la
vulnérabilité a été approché par ben
rennais brand
cette chercheuse américaine en sciences
sociales
elle a dit que la vulnérabilité
c'est être susceptibles d'être touchés
blessé sur le plan physique ou
psychologique
mais être vulnérable c'est vous n'avez
jamais été touché par la vulnérabilité
d'un homme touché par la vulnérabilité
d'une femme d'un enfant d'un paysage
oui
la vulnérabilité est un réel pouvoir
contre la violence pour moi être un
homme sur un chemin qui a du coeur s'est
activée c'est s'ouvrir à sa
vulnérabilité
être un homme sur le chemin qui a du
coeur c'est prendre sa responsabilité
c'est utiliser le pouvoir du choix être
un homme sur un chemin qui a du coeur
c'est agir de manière à ligné et avec
intégrité
oui je me suis sentie vulnérables
si je prends quelques secondes la ici
maintenant et que je pense à notre
planète ne la trouvez vous pas
vulnérable je pense qu'il est temps de
prendre notre responsabilité est d'agir
a vite avec un alignement
je pense qu'il est vraiment temps car
lyon me disait tu n'es pas ce qui s'est
passé
tu es ce que tu choisis et tu décides de
devenir il est temps de devenir des
hommes
il est temps de devenir humain est de
prendre notre juste place sur ce sur
cette planète d'agir en conscience avec
responsabilité et 1 et intégrité
il est juste temps merci
[Applaudissements]